what's up it's your boy young murder
Myrtle Beach you know what I'm saying
check me out on the bootleg Kev podcast
show special guest [ __ ] murder
Beats
what we're gonna do is we're in a
microdose to start the interview
we're on camera but we're gonna do one
you're gonna turn down oh man this guy
just do one bro I'll do one do one do it
for Canada bruh
do it for the Homeland
I actually like these ones a lot too
they're tasty
they're pretty good hopefully this makes
for much more interesting uh
conversation let's do it we'll find out
in about 15 huh
we'll see I'm gonna take two just so you
know I'm with the shits you'll have
you'll be on one I'll be on two
wait this is really shrooms
this is really shrooms I mean officially
um
no of course not no this was [ __ ]
candy yeah shout out to 7-Eleven
anyway man welcome back thanks man how's
everything been everything's good man
you know new record new record enjoying
life dabbling into the Spanish World got
J Balvin on it how did it start out did
it start out with quavo giving you that
hook and you were like oh this is crazy
yeah so it actually started yeah like it
started this is like one of the beats
that actually started with another
producer this started with Pharrell an
idea from Pharrell you know what I'm
saying I I called him up got the files
collaborated on it with them and stuff
quavo killed it I got Balvin on it like
around the same time like I heard it and
then um I put my girl Anita on it too
you know what I'm saying she's from
Brazil put the cherry on top is she from
Brazil yeah she's from Brazil have you
been there yeah how was it I was there
like I went with her like a month ago
maybe it was crazy are you single no no
okay never mind then how are the women
out there like if you were single were
they Anita's great honestly do I just
mean like Brazil as a country Brazil is
a beautiful country as a Young Man
Brazilian was like my favorite category
to go to on the Hub you know Brazilian
women are amazing yeah don't get enough
of them in L.A unfortunately yeah you're
right honestly yeah shout out to Brazil
good I got a Brazilian myself you know
oh you have a Brazilian girl yeah also
then you know more than anyone yeah
kudos to you sir Anita she's great oh
Anita's your girl yeah what the [ __ ] I
had no idea yeah she's lit dude that was
so awkward the fact I didn't know that
no she's like it's it's the streams man
it's not the shrooms I just had no
[ __ ] idea man apparently I'm not
tapped in enough nah she's dope though I
met her like last year in Miami and then
we just kept talking and stuff and then
like started like hanging out a lot and
then like she brought me out of
Coachella and then yeah you know what
I'm saying and now that's your lady
that's dope awesome I like she had a
record with the baby that was dope yeah
yeah no she's she's super far she's
killing it that's super good she just
got like a Guinness World Record for
like
the highest streaming Latin song solo
Latin artist song or something you might
know this better than me
because in Brazil it's a Portuguese
speaking country yeah I'm learning
Portuguese right now yeah and Portuguese
is like uh my homie's from Portugal so
he'd be sometimes he'll speak that [ __ ]
in front of me and it's definitely a
different language than Spanish but I
think it's kind of tricky to learn I
don't know Spanish it's probably easier
like I've learned French and stuff
because French is the second language in
Canada Canada yeah but Portuguese is
kind of difficult you know but you're
learning she's teaching you what is
something that you've learned like that
you're like confident you know you get
into a pinch you need to bust out a
Portuguese sentence what are we saying
insane she
what does that mean innocent and it's oh
[ __ ] in case the police pull up you're
like like so there was one day like I
saw some crazy [ __ ] on the side of the
street we were like driving and like it
was like a cop and they had all these
people like in handcuffs on this on the
on the road and like everyone had AKs
and [ __ ] and her mom was like suspect
though or like suspect though and then
like I learned innocent it was funny I
like learned how to say insanity or
whatever like innocent and then like I
was in like a grocery store there and
like a guy walked out right when I
walked in and the beat the alarm
and I was like oh [ __ ] and then like
everyone's like hey hey hey you you like
what's going like they're all looking at
me like I just like stole something like
they're all like we got him like they're
like we got this this kid from Canada
like we got it you were able to use it
though and then they're like walk back
through the metal detector like in
Portuguese I'm like I'm like I'm like
this and I walk down like insane sheet
and I walked through and it didn't beep
and everyone was like laughing it's
gonna feel great to be able to get off a
word like that that you just learned it
was great it's like perfect circumstance
no it was fun uh so Pharrell co-produced
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] cool
legendary shout out to Pharrell you know
he's one of the goats he's like on the
uh the Mount Rushmore I'd say hell yeah
you know legendary yeah what uh what's
your relationship like with Pharrell
because
um I met him at cuevos
album release party 2018. remember when
Cleveland dropped his album
um I met him at that release party
and then he he said that he was a big
fan and stuff we should link up and then
we kept in touch I started going to
Studio with him working on a lot of
stuff and then this record came about
years later right so it was awesome so
like we definitely wanted to release
something together you know what I'm
saying and then this was perfect so when
you like get the beat originally from
Pharrell
who's one of the greats what is the
sauce you add to it I like
put some of my drums with his drums and
made it crazier and then like did some
Melody stuff produced out the record put
everybody on the record and like yeah
super big and like we both like did
notes for like mixing and mastering he
helped me like with some notes like take
it to the Finish Line like things and
like how to tweak like sequencing the
song and stuff yeah I didn't think this
is gonna be a huge record for you bro no
I appreciate it because as soon as I
heard it I was like oh this [ __ ] I told
my boy Brandon uh from your label I was
like yo this is uh this would be easy
you know what I mean yeah I shot a big
budget video in Miami big budget video
what is a big budget video in 2022 I'm
just curious because I think back in the
day they were like really big budget
videos
um big budget video for me
is like
3K
like over like 500 000 half a million
that's that's fair you know it's a big
budget yeah for sure yeah because I feel
like back in the day like when Buster
Rhymes and Missy and big those were like
they were like [ __ ] millions of
dollars like think about the Mo Money Mo
Problems video yeah this [ __ ]
had to shut down the ocean and they had
speed boats and [ __ ] oh yeah that [ __ ]
was crazy yeah videos those times were
incredible so what is the J Balvin call
like
so I was in I was in LA at the time it
was like during covet I was working with
Balvin so you were already locked in
with him yeah so I was working with him
already this [ __ ] fly won't go away
shut up shut up the Flies yeah but um I
was already working with him and stuff
so like when I had the record like when
I got the record and stuff I was like yo
this is gonna be perfect to get Balvin
on right so I took it right to him he
loved it he's like yo this is super fire
can't wait to do it he sent me like a
verse back in like a week that's a
pretty nice turnaround for arguably the
biggest artist in the [ __ ] and then
we were kind of we were kind of sitting
on the record for a bit I thought cuevo
might was gonna use it you know and then
he ended up not using this on top of the
year I was like Hey man can I get this
for my shirt yeah yeah is that something
that happens like because obviously you
you're putting out a lot of music so
is that something that is happening with
you picking songs where you'll be like
yo I we cut this idea like a year and a
half ago what are you doing with it
because I wouldn't mind yes sometimes
but then a lot of Like Rappers and stuff
they'll feel like stuff's old and
they'll just want to make new stuff yeah
always that's a problem because a lot of
the rappers that like I work with they
just record so fast so they're always
recording new music so something I feel
like all artists are like that where
it's like um
it could be nine months old it could be
a year old and they're like yo man but
it's that's just old it's played out you
know it's crazy I feel like that that is
something that happens we're out here
artists play me [ __ ] and I'll be like yo
that's a hit you should drop that [ __ ]
and then like a year later their album
comes out and the [ __ ] Sure Shot
[ __ ] Banger did not make the project
and I'm like what the [ __ ] and it's
because [ __ ] drive around
listening to their own [ __ ] it gets
played out to them they do the new [ __ ]
and they're like yeah no it's crazy man
and that's the thing it's like a lot of
artists they like forget about the the
gems
like dude there's been so many artists
from my dude you had you had you had a
[ __ ] big record that you just kept on
kept on a hard drive somewhere yeah so
you're you're kind of running into that
just with because obviously when you're
reaching out you're like yo I love this
idea we cut yeah even even for me though
like I put records together in like 2018
with like all big name major artists and
then I just listened to it too much and
it gets like a year old and I'm like
it's too old I need new [ __ ] oh so you
everyone's like yo no like we need to
drop this like this is fire so that's
happened with you it happens all the
time man I'm sitting on so much music
what would you say is
give me the artist
on a song that you've decided to just
not drop
um or that you're kind of like it's a
little old I might pass
I might still drop it right it's got
like I might like renew the beat or
something but like I got like a bunch of
stuff with a bunch of people but one
example is like uh swaely two chains
Gucci that's a nice record you know um
this feels like 2018 though yeah but
still yeah but still you got anything on
the new Rae Sherman project uh I don't
think so
sit down that one right
should have took that one super fire
he's like yo I had one for him I got
some [ __ ] just need to send Jimmy to hop
on it yeah it's a race rumored Zone
yeah for sure man
um so I you know you you have a lot of
stuff that you have your hands in talk
about the water that you got it's is it
psychedelic water is that what it's
called yeah [ __ ] that up yeah it's
called psychedelic water we got it in
like air one we got it in a bunch of
stores it's going crazy right now
um right now the product that we have in
stores because you obviously can't you
know what I'm saying but um you can't
put uh psilocybin in water and sell it
you can't put like mushrooms in water
and put it in Walmart so it's like
unless you're in Canada
I think so it's legal in Canada
well whiz just announced he's dropping
his own shrooms in Canada yeah that's
good Mr cap it makes sense good enough
now you got to do your [ __ ] yeah so
right now what we have is it's like
kavaru Dominion Leaf like just stuff
that's like if you drink it you you'll
get a little buzz like I drink it I get
a little buzz I feel good energetic and
stuff like it's cool just [ __ ] fly
there is um there's like a lot of like
legal mushrooms that are like super
beneficial though like like there's like
I take this supplement
um
it's like bro when I'm taking this [ __ ]
because I never get sick
what the [ __ ] it's called it's um it's
on Amazon for like 100 a bottle but that
[ __ ] is gas shout out to the shrooms how
often do you like micro dosing through
life uh
I I dabble sometimes I don't know not
really though you've been wearing like
heavy like a heavy trip no you've never
[ __ ] talked to God or a [ __ ]
um had one of those [ __ ] step moments
maybe back in the day
back in the day this guy is you got
psychedelic Waters the name of your
water brand and you've never had a crazy
experience no I've had a crazy
experience like yeah we just don't want
to talk about it if that's a few shares
you know what I mean what's been the
worst trip you've ever had
um
or the best trip
could go either way it's like I don't
know it's like laughing a lot and stuff
you know it's fun you know I discovered
Tame Impala
I've always heard of Tame Impala never
knew it was one guy I always did you
know it was one guy that I always
thought it was some [ __ ] Mega band
because I thought they like headline
Coachella a few years ago I was [ __ ]
off a whole bag of these joints like
[ __ ] Joshua Tree like a real [ __ ]
La [ __ ] who going to Joshua Tree
to do shrooms and I just threw on some
playlists called like shrew music on
Spotify and that [ __ ] Tame Impala
came on versus the [ __ ] best [ __ ] I
ever heard in my life at the time being
high on shrooms listening to let it
happen by Tame Impala that was the best
that's the best song in I've ever heard
in life I used to I used to smoke a lot
of weed I used to love coming to La like
back in the day I'd come to La I'd like
pull up on a dispensary I like do a
story post they give me like they give
you hey yo yo take an outs but this is
like even before like they even had like
crazy branding out here in L.A like 20
like 15 like it was getting started yeah
but like you know what I'm saying but I
just started getting like super anxious
off weed a lot like it just like started
like hitting me differently and I so I
just like I remember like one year after
Coachella I was like you have to
Coachella I'm just gonna completely stop
smoking weed and I just stopped and like
I haven't smoked weed like like like if
I'm like drunk and you have a plant like
I'll hit the block right it makes sense
but like yeah I haven't smoked weed and
like like I quit we probably like five
six years ago you think that increased
uh your like productivity in life
um did you notice anything like get
better
I definitely leveled up in life but I
don't know if it was because I stopped
smoking weeds five percent to do with it
you're like I don't know
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our family our
good Folks at Odd Socks you see me look
these are some Odd Socks Basics on my
skinny white [ __ ] legs I love Odd
Socks go to oddsocksofficial.com you're
gonna get 20 off at checkout if you use
the promo code bootleg Kev that's one
word bootleg Kev now they got Odd Socks
which are great my favorites are the
basics they also you know you got the
license one these are the Twizzlers
these are Baywatch socks but then you
got the basics now these are what these
are just the plain boys man they're so
comfy all right I always got the white
Basics the black Basics on and I always
got Odd Socks underwear on too they got
the draws all right so what are you
doing go to oddstocksofficial.com use
the promo code
bootleg Kev save 20 off check out these
[ __ ] draws Kool-Aid underwear ladies
and gentlemen what are we doing
oddsoxofficial.com bootleg Kev is the
promo code save 20 off right now let's
get back to the interview uh you are
from Canada
I want to know your thoughts on uh the
new Drake album
I like it I like it too I'm not mad at
it I'm just glad he took a risk I
actually like it like I know like when
he first dropped it and stuff like a lot
of people were like I saw like people
bashing it and stuff and I was in Canada
at the time and um I was like driving
back to Niagara to see my mom and I was
just playing the album and I was like
this is fire music to ride to it's just
like you need to have refreshing music
you know what I'm saying and I feel like
when you travel a lot and you experience
different cultures and different parts
of the world and there's a lot of
different music out there right so I
just feel like he's introducing like a
new sound to like
I think like for me I think Drake
taking a risk is I'm I'm just happy I'm
like yo this dude just put out a whole
[ __ ] house album like
I'm just happy he's taking risks with
his music because I feel like Drake
could do anything like he could just do
the Drake [ __ ] and it'll work
like but he could do like he could just
make the Same album over and over again
not saying he's done that
I think my favorite maybe yes
um my favorite record on the album on
that album is sticky Sticky's the one
shout out to [ __ ] Carnage that's my
joint yeah he snapping that [ __ ] stick
he's crazy super crazy and then I know I
think he I think he's gonna be putting
out
I don't know they're saying he might do
another scary hours you got any
unreleased Drake
um I had some but we ended up using it
what's that mean
um like you use the beat or you use
Drake's vocals or not like like me and
Drake were gonna work a record but then
we put it we gave it to two chains for
bigger than you um great record that's a
great record too that was a great record
shout out to shout out shout out to
James me and 2 Chainz has a lot of
success together man we had that one
bigger than you we got It's A vibe and
we had 4 AM
there's like three bags all three four
am with Travis it's a Bible quavo no
it's about no it's high Janae and Trey
on it right yeah Banger wow that's a
that's like a classic record that could
be played anywhere anytime that's a
great record anytime yeah any Vibe it's
a Vibe it's crazy 4am was that was one
of the better records on that album too
yeah that whole that was crazy
have you like ever thought about like
lock like if you see someone like two
chains where you got a great uh
chemistry with them like doing like a
whole [ __ ] album or your executive
producer yeah hell yeah we talked about
it you know what I'm saying you might
have to revisit it have you done that
with anyone
like five years ago yeah how was that I
love that project smoke Purp
I don't he has some dope [ __ ] I don't
know what happened with that kid man you
just underrated man
Under Fire he's a good he's a good
artist I think like that whole era
the cloud era whatever you want to call
it
I just think that like it chewed up a
lot of people to spit them out bro no
for sure you know what I'm saying it's
just like that whole era of music like
just like the times and music are
changing so fast now right I understand
so it's like
people can get lost in it you know yeah
like you think of like
like little pump smoke perp even six
nine uh who else was popping during that
he probably can't see anyone's name
because I can be a dick you can uh I
don't know you get it
um yeah yeah it just felt like a lot of
those guys like
the music was like good enough at the
time because the Antics were up there in
terms of like you know people like
actually like going like and paying
attention to what they were doing and
the music was like ah checks out like a
little pump had some [ __ ] I loved but I
think like once people stop giving a
[ __ ] about like Instagram Antics as much
the music really had to like stack up
and I just feel like sometimes like
those guys weren't as focused on making
great music as they were like making
okay music and being like [ __ ] rap
stars you know what I mean I get where
you're coming from I I personally like
loved like this the [ __ ] that me and
purple are making though right fire
album like I think like Lil xan like
what the [ __ ] man God bless him yeah
Jesus his music was atrocious but like
he was little Zan God Bless yeah that
one song what was that song called was
it uh the Skittles one the [ __ ] was it
called or somehow [ __ ] tasting like
Skittles or something you only have one
good song but shout out to him um are
you like I just had um
South Side on the show last month and he
was saying that what he deals with a lot
is people selling bootleg Southside
Beats
so we're like people because his tags
everywhere so he's like yo people take
my tag and they'll put it on their
shitty the 808 Mafia tag they'll put it
on their shitty beats and they're like
people will [ __ ] actually really
think that it's real [ __ ] no they'll
cash out this struggle producer or
whoever it is have you had anyone like
have you ever had some [ __ ] drop like
randomly that has your tag you're like I
didn't do that [ __ ] beat yeah I've
had that happen I've had people put my
name on records just a lot of stuff yeah
it happens though it happens like when
you when you get success you know what
I'm saying people are gonna try to like
use your name to like get one up or
something you know what I'm saying yeah
is there any uh do you deal with this a
lot where maybe like I don't know five
years ago you sent a pack to somebody
and or you were in a session with
somebody that kind of idea and they
tried dropping it like and you gotta
like shut that [ __ ] down oh yeah that's
happened before too yeah it's gonna be I
can imagine just you being a kid coming
up [ __ ] traveling to Atlanta to work
with Amigos how many random sessions
you've been in where people have gotten
your Beats yeah I used to always try to
like not like delete my beats off the
computer this that blah blah you know
what I'm saying that's smart most people
don't do people record here all the
[ __ ] time
and I'm just like the lack of like care
people have to like take their [ __ ] off
did they just leave their [ __ ] on the
computer oh yes where I had like half a
g herbo's album on my [ __ ] laptop
with stems and everything on the
computer there it album's out now but
it's like do you guys want these like
nine months later yo can you send the
sessions [ __ ] man bring a hard drive you
do you always bring the hard drive you
always got to have the hard drive um
like like Wii transfers you know stuff
like that USBS yeah of course uh what
for you man like stepping into the
Spanish world it's something new for you
so like uh you're obviously a Caucasian
from Canada yeah I'm white you're you're
white We're White
uh what is like how are you digging it
so far
it's cool man I'm just always just
trying to like do new stuff and like
right stay refreshing for myself you
know what I'm saying like I feel like
I've done a lot and like I just want to
like keep having fun with it and like
try new things and like you know what
I'm saying it's good like even like
during covet like I was like I was like
yo I want to like do some different
stuff and I got the opportunity to like
get connected with Ariana Grande and
then we work during covid on face time
and then started linking up and like
we're just working on music for her
album and stuff we did some records and
just like doing different stuff you know
like a year ago like I did the Chloe
Bailey half Mercy record big record yeah
just like just like having fun with it
doing different stuff you know I'm
saying I never want to be put in a box
and I always want to be remembered for
being able to make like all different
kinds of music was it hard for you to
get out of the box having a name like
murder beats initially
um
it wasn't hard getting out of the box
because the rap records I was making I
was part of that time where like those
records were becoming mainstream pop
records of course but definitely like
with the name like I remember like years
ago like people were telling me to like
change my name like use my government
name Shane Lindstrom on my producer
stuff I was like hell no because like I
was like I can't do that because I just
like built this brand right and like I
spent years of my life building this
[ __ ] to what to throw it away and to
change my name I can't do that yeah man
when you think of like uh and that was a
groundwork Like Me by myself like I did
like I really started it obviously like
when I brought more pieces of the puzzle
like met my manager and [ __ ] we took it
to the next level but like all those
nights in my mom's basement and like on
Twitter and doing all that stuff and
moving around Chicago moving around
Atlanta by myself like so much sleepless
nights and stuff you know what I'm
saying my Blood Sweat and Tears into
that name can't switch it yeah can you
imagine Shane Shane Beats
can Shane beats are there there's got to
be at least four or five guys man that's
crazy right shout out to Shane yeah
shout out to Shane it's a great name man
it's a great name
um unique yeah but like when we think of
the Spanish [ __ ] bro it's like worldly
music so it's like you know I always you
know
it's worthy and it's Latin America yeah
Latin America is Big it's huge it's like
the biggest genre of music in the world
bro
and like it's going to open you up to
like so much different spaces do you you
don't really do you like you do gigs
sometimes where you do all right yeah
I was kicking it I'd be DJing in um
Vegas and stuff how's that it's fun man
I have a blast so now you can go DJ in
Barcelona or [ __ ] Brazil yeah we're
Puerto Rico yeah you know what I'm
saying Puerto Rico's the vibe not real
[ __ ] yeah I like Puerto Rico I went out
there like a couple years ago for my
birthday I was like there was like a
there was like a moment in my trip where
I was like on an ATV right at the the
forest it was like raining and it was
like oh God I was like yo this is crazy
yeah where am I at right now yeah I felt
like I was in like rainforest like is
that a rainforest if it's a forest and
it's raining [ __ ] that's a good question
because I was gonna say rainforest but I
didn't want to say rainforest yes but if
it was a forest and it was raining
technically there's an argument to be
made there
does anyone know
this is the type of questions you asked
when the micro dose kicks in if you're
in a forest and it rains are you now in
a rainforest have you ever been
have you ever been to Rainforest Cafe
yes I literally was in Niagara Falls
with my mom and we like we like walk by
the falls like week like literally a few
weeks ago like we went to Rainforest
Cafe you went recently first time like I
was like where should we eat I was like
I'm starving I'm like there's a
Rainforest Cafe right there I'm like oh
let me go I haven't been there since I
was like eight dude when I was a little
when I was a little kid that was like uh
the biggest thing we had in Arizona they
opened this new lawn there was a
Rainforest Cafe and it was like there's
animatronic I think [ __ ] in Arizona uh
well now there's a little bit of stuff
there's animals moving and there's like
[ __ ] animatronic alligators it was
like a tourist attraction like the food
who gives a [ __ ] yo the craziest [ __ ] is
is like
when you remember like restaurants used
to eat as a kid like nostalgic feelings
like I remember like back in the day I
wouldn't even eat there we were too poor
to eat there but we would just stand
there my parents like we were like a big
a big big dinner would be like to go to
like Red Lobster it'd be like oh my God
this is like Gourmet five star you know
what I'm saying I used to think
Applebee's was fancy bro yeah Chili's
all that stuff Phillies I was like damn
we're going to Chili's I tried to go
back good day yo me and my boys like I
was driving by at Chili's like six
months ago I was like yo we gotta this
guy I gotta go try it like you know what
I'm saying I I hopped out we ate a
choice it was I thought it was terrible
probably was I thought it was terrible
but like but like the Nostalgia of me
going like with my parents when I was a
kid driving over to Buffalo going to the
Galleria mall going to eat at Chili's
like it was like incredible you know
what I mean you guys would go to Buffalo
to eat yeah that's tight because I I
grew up in Fort Erie it's like on the
border of Buffalo it's like five minute
drive to Buffalo so you're right there
so it's like people go there to shop
like America has like a lot of better
Brands shopping malls cheaper gas better
food in grocery stores like everything
you know cheaper gas yeah yeah [ __ ] it's
like that are you still a Canadian
citizen obviously yeah so you get free
healthcare no no not anymore I spend too
much time here bootleg cab podcast got
to stop things real quick tell you about
our good Folks at Blue chew listen
fellas if you're trying to get your dick
right you're trying to stay harder
everyone wants to be hard can you stay
hard
you know what I mean
if you need some help with your dick is
essentially what I'm trying to say
you need to go to bluetooth.com and get
down with uh something that I feel like
is imperative and having yourself a
lovely evening with a lovely young lady
or male whatever you're into if you go
to bluetooth.com you will get a
Bluetooth it has the same active
ingredient as Cialis and his Viagra
right but guess what it doesn't have the
awkward doctor visits that's right you
don't gotta wait in line at some Lobby
to go get you some [ __ ] [ __ ] to get
your dick working and have some awkward
conversation with a nurse and then have
an awkward conversation with a doctor
and then he writes you a prescription
and then you go to the pharmacist and
then it's awkward because you pass them
the prescription and everyone knows
you're picking up dick stuff you know
what I'm saying no Bluetooth you go to
the website it's all online It Gets Sent
straight to your house in discreet
packaging in a chewable form listen your
first month free right now when you go
to bluetooth.com and you use the promo
code bootleg that's right you get the
first month for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg
take me later all right go get your dick
together fellas what do you think of the
Trudeau guy
I feel like people are like I feel like
he's like a polarizing guy I don't know
man I don't know man I think he kind of
[ __ ] up during the whole quarantine
and stuff [ __ ] people down and like
turning Canada into like different
country a little bit it was crazy right
yeah it was crazy because like I was
over here so I was like I don't know
everyone's calling me back home like we
can't even leave the house and [ __ ] like
I don't know about y'all like [ __ ] I'm
on the beach right now yeah
um
Buffalo is uh I went to Buffalo one time
last year and hung out with the gazelle
the guys and
pretty interesting place good food
though but interesting like I remember
the Griselda guys like I used to go to
Buffalo and try to like figure out like
try to like build myself in the Buffalo
Market way back like I used to go hang
out with John Boy there was a rapper
John Boy out there shout out John Boy
and like he he brought me to the studio
where Conway was and I met Conway like
way back then wow and like their like
boy was trying to like buy my drums off
me for like 25 bucks I was like was it
there like 75 they're like no deal was
it Derringer trying to marriage rooms I
think it was um DJ Shay all right all
right guy yeah did you ever link with
Derringer back then I don't know
Derringer is like a [ __ ] I don't
think so he's like the new like I just
get like real like new Rizza new
he reminds me of the original okay yeah
shout out to Derringer but yeah like
that whole Buffalo scene and then like
then like you know what I'm saying like
me coming up you know what I'm saying
getting success in the business and then
seeing the gazelle the guys pop up and
be like oh wait I met them back because
they're five minutes apart I was like
that's crazy you know what I'm saying so
I've been sending packs and stuff to
Conway and stuff I was on his last album
yeah shout out to shout out to Mr Conway
are you running were you on the uh one
that came out on Shady
I don't know is I did a record called
anzia
anzia
shots to Mission the machine
um hey so are are you doing all this to
do the album eventually are you only
focused dropping singles because we had
a dope Blast from Wale record earlier
this year is this leading up to a
project or are you just gonna drop songs
it'll definitely lead up to something
but right now I'm just dropping music
you know what I'm saying yeah getting it
out the door just songs just having fun
with it you know what I'm saying just Do
you feel like you're trying to like
essentially uh well I'm not even gonna
ask that question because I don't want
to disrespect anybody uh
um
albums
eventually yeah we'll go there yeah uh
anything else going on bro like what
else you got going on man just enjoy
myself man you know what I'm saying
working on music you know what I'm
saying DJing you know what I'm saying
when you DJ these gigs
is it like what percent like are you
playing all your [ __ ] I play some of my
[ __ ] like it's like I'm DJing for two
hours yeah so you gotta also like you
also gotta like like all your records
like you know obviously they're they're
hits but like you also got to play the
[ __ ] that's like yeah I'm trying to
Super popping in the moment I like to
party yeah so it's like when you come to
a Myrtle Beach show like yeah you're
gonna have a great time partying with me
because I'm gonna just play this [ __ ]
like that everyone's gonna have a good
time like you know what I'm saying like
anyone who comes to the show is gonna
enjoy themselves
was it a hard transition producing the
DJing
um I know it's easier at the beginning I
didn't even want a DJ I was like I don't
want to be DJ I don't want a DJ and then
like start show offers start coming in
like no no I don't want a DJ don't want
a DJ and then my manager's like oh well
like we have this uh New Year's Eve
offer in Hawaii and like we could go for
a week and go to Hawaii for a week yeah
it's like I'm like all right [ __ ] it
let's do it that's how I think that's
how like we started DJing and stuff then
going on tours and stuff and then I did
Coachella 2019 I did Coachella this year
with Anita
shout out to Anita hey what's the first
date like with murder beats in Anita
what do you guys do with like how did
you how did you convince her to you know
make things official you know what I
mean because I I too am a coffee I'm a
great guy dating a lovely Latin woman
and you know so we're kind of similar
we're very similar shout out to my wife
you know what I'm saying um but you know
yeah with some I had to put some work in
for sure and I'm not I'm not murdered I
just kept seeing her out and stuff and
then just like you know what I'm saying
we kept talking here and there and then
like kept talking more and more and more
and then just like invite her out to eat
in LA and then like what's the
restaurant you take I went to nice guy
nice guy and then we went bowling one
night and then yeah bowling in the
valley
um
I don't know like everyone Hollywood
oh in Hollywood yeah they rented our
little thing you know oh you ran you
just rented the whole room I mean you
you know something light some low-key
you know so something low-key get the
whole [ __ ] bowling alley together no
not the whole one just just the area
just a little something yeah uh are you
are you interested in doing anything
else in terms of just starting new
businesses uh always man always you know
what I'm saying you got to diversify
you're you gotta if you had to start a
restaurant bro what kind of restaurant
would you start sushi sushi Murda beat
sushi yeah I like that will that be a
stupid name you'd have to come up with a
better name than murder beat sushi
like hmm
murder fish no no
no it's not a fish are being murdered
I'm not gonna lie it's kicking in for me
it's great my lights are bright [ __ ]
right can we dim them a little bit
can we dim the lights Cyrus yeah what do
you think about his joke I was just
joking
no you're fine go sit down bro
they're [ __ ] kind of breaks down bruh
all right so look at that hotel lobbies
out right now too that's like I [ __ ]
love this record it's you and quavo yeah
will take off shot hey what's up listen
you got the inside info these guys
breaking up the Migos nah I don't think
no one's breaking up I mean aren't they
all related yeah it's all it's our
family you know what I'm saying
okay
so are they breaking up though man I
don't know man you know what I'm saying
I'll get the breaking up you know what
I'm saying
um you know you [ __ ] look away
he said he said I don't I don't know I
don't know they're breaking up
but I just I can't look at you and I say
that no you know you know what it is you
know what I'm saying family's family
yeah man yeah Brotherly Love brotherly
love oh yeah because they're all like
very related like it ain't like they're
like uh yeah quavo is takeoff's uncle
wow and then offsets the cousin I'm
pretty sure
um yeah
it's pretty cool
so if they do break up
you executive producing the first take
off cuevo album
I don't think they'll break up but if
they do is it just me go with like
parentheses and an s or like Amigos one
true
Amiga
what if it's migos-ish
meager
yeah I don't know oh we we're not
talking about this anymore your guy just
opened the door he's like yo shut the
[ __ ] up about the Migos bro and this
breakup Jesus can you can we can we
[ __ ] cut it out anyway no one's
breaking up you know what I'm saying I
like this guy's shirt Garth Brooks wear
a similar shirt on the cover of his
album from like 91 and my dad had that
CD in this car forever you [ __ ] Garth
Brooks my grandma used to play Garth
Brooks all the time bro Garth Brooks is
the he's like goaded he's the goat right
he sells out [ __ ] I'm pretty sure he
sold more records than anybody in the
90s it was him or Mariah crazy man shout
out to Garth Brooks Man Would You Do
country because 100 countries getting
there I've made some I've made some
stuff with Sam Hunt before in Nashville
Sam Hunt yeah that's not Sam Smith [ __ ]
no he's a big deal though no I know he
is I just can't look at him right now in
my head because I don't I only like uh
Garth Brooks who else is hard in country
uh Elvis no the fat guy Luke Combs is
[ __ ] gas Morgan Wallen you guys look
like you could be related no offense
he's actually my cousin is he yeah
second cousin tight
wait Morgan Wallen is actually your
cousin no I'm joking
I was about the same ah let's dive into
that rabbit hole
well there it is murder beats the new
song No Mas yep no mas out everywhere
uh hotel lobbies out hotel lobby out
everywhere uh new song with swaely Gucci
Mane and two chains for 2018 maybe
coming soon
maybe maybe maybe there it is Blue Lake
Camp show